says going live so it's going live all
right it says we are live okay excellent
and hello and welcome everyone to the
round table with the stream team and
this is where we talk to amazing content
creators and their journeys to where
they are today today we have the amazing
mr. boomstick excel with us and he's you
know excited to be here you are excited
to be here we've been talking for like a
half-hour yeah
excellent great I'm happy to have you
here so tonight we're gonna we're gonna
ask boomstick a couple of questions
about you know his you know his outlook
on what he's been doing and there's you
know in life in general what he's been
doing with all of his podcasts and
everything and I'm very excited to to
get half him here to to you know ask him
all of these questions and tonight we
have l-boogie Oh - Oh ate with us how
are you Elle not too bad hanging in
there we uh we all from the party
oh no no party i i've been recouping
like non-stop I'm still cold
my cold oh man with the lost voice well
I was just been crazy but I've been
popping medicine the doctor gave me
every night and finally feeling good so
it's great so MJ he's unable to make it
this evening he has some you know some
College stuff to do as our our college
guy or young young man running around
doing his thing and old school
unfortunately he has worked on Tuesdays
so so he's kind of in there yes he's in
the bushes
probably cursing and very angry silly
man doing his work so um so let's start
this off boomstick tell us tell us where
you why you wanted to become a concert
creator where this ended up starting and
you know like tell us tell us that tell
us everything cuz I I can't wait to hear
your story of why you wanted to become a
concert creator you know it's funny it's
actually it's it's it's it's simple you
know my first video was uh my first van
sure into YouTube where I put my first
video up which is still up you can see
it it's terrible it's awful it is it is
is the sounds is off I I don't have a
proper thumbnail I think I have
Wolfenstein running in the back it was
it was awful it was remember third 2017
so that's that was actually my first you
know when I started the channel and
prior to that you know obviously my I
come from a law enforcement background
right so for 21 years I served the
amazing people of New York City and
prior to that I was in the United States
Navy during Desert Storm the first the
first assault in that country I didn't
cross seas I I was I didn't spend a lot
of time in the Navy but I did serve this
country during wartime and I was always
into video games it doesn't matter what
job I had and especially like in the
police department you know when I first
got on I was course very young it was 20
I was 21 I was I got when I was a baby
and it was littered with dinosaurs the
older guys you know guys had for 10 15
20 years on and when I started talking
about playing video games I was
ostracized to say the least
video games what do you play Atari you
know I'm saying that it was it was it
was grueling but now he's become so
mainstream that it's it's you're weird
if you don't play right so now you're
getting into content creation see back
in the days prior to me doing my own
thing
I was a regular media you know you know
I love the IGN's I love gamer tag radio
I love giant bomb I love the second show
I watched all of these shows religiously
and I say watch really more so I
listened and then 2014 happened and what
happened in 2014 well there Xbox one
released and it seemed as if the the
media darlings that were the Xbox 360
there was a shift in perception
mm-hmm and what started happening was
you know III I've always been a support
I have owned and I really truly mean
this I've owned every console in
existence going back all the way to 1978
when I got my first Atari 2600 I have I
it's a it's my only hobby I don't drink
I don't smoke I've never done drugs I'm
not the party guy but my vice there's
always ill games so I've always proudly
supported everything you know back in
the days you know you look at that there
like for instance the the turbo graphics
era there was a multiple a multitude of
consoles I had them all
I loved supporting all the consoles but
it seemed as there was a shift in the
way the media was telling the story of
Xbox even though I enjoyed the
PlayStation 3 at you know and I couldn't
wait for the get my hands on the
PlayStation 4 the Xbox was always where
I kind of laid my head I loved the
achievement of Xbox Live I love my
friends list that all came with me and
then it started where I I wasn't happy
with the mainstream media anymore I kind
of lost a lot of love for them because
they turned on Xbox and I understand the
Xbox you know made a lot of mistakes but
the turn was was unbelievable so I
started my accident I accidentally
tripped into YouTube having content
creators because a lot of her kids were
like oh I watched you too and I'm like
what do you watch on YouTube like I like
an old man would say like so you know
about how old are you and you when you
realize this believe it or not do it I
was let's see okay well and I just
turned 49 right somebody 50 next year
and I was probably in my in my 40s yeah
we're like you you watch YouTube like I
just watch trailers and stuff on there I
didn't know that there was this whole
hidden content Asian community there so
I accidentally found
and crossfire well Riddler yeah that
that was the one of the first shows that
I found which was I receive it's it's
run its run by mooch right oh and and
you know he's had crack gamer i receive
been on there for a lot of years I don't
know I mean the cast has changed over
the years now you have clowns you have
predator h2o
xbox four four four eight he's been on
there and you know it's R its rotated
throughout the years and then the second
show I found with the iron Lords podcast
thanks to my brother Neil mental do they
go do that check out these guys I am
Lord they're they're fantastic and I
started listening to him and I started
saying oh you know something these guys
their opinions they're kind of like my
opinions we may not agree in their own
but I like the way they're talking about
games and you know I used to be you know
that that fan for IGN that you know I
paid the $30.00 a year that you know to
keep the lights on for them but Ron the
cat always asked I was I patreon to all
these guys I I did all the extra I
backed out of everything I am subscribed
to all of them as you know what this
other community here was really
something special
mmm-hmm so you're saying that like you
know you you love the content creation
you loved i GN you you kind of started
like you know that that process did you
always like want to be one of those
those people one of those like writers
or one of those people that always
wanted to be on IGN on one of those
publications it's funny you should say
that because I've always wanted to be a
writer mm-hmm I've always wanted to
write about video games
I thought I thought it was it to me it
seemed pretty unbelievable that a hobby
that I love I could logistically get
paid for writing mm-hmm and you know and
and I saw it interests me you know I you
know I started my own blog and I used to
do these you know do my own reviews and
kind of put them out there no one read
them yeah but I was doing them because
you know it was I was enjoying I was
enjoying writing of torture
writing about games and you know I'd get
a message every now and again hey you
know this is a really good you know you
really good you know review whatever
thanks so much I just bought the game
yeah and little things like that you
like oh wow wow that's pretty cool yeah
so sorry to break your train of thought
but you were going to say you go ahead I
had to ask
so no that's part that's that's actually
a great question so what wound up
happening that the real short of it is
this on my personal bucket list and I
think we all have that right everybody
wants to go do you know a certain amount
of things before the end of the road
right I mean that's just I think it's
everybody one of the things that were on
the so called
quote-unquote imaginary buckle it was to
be on a podcast and I'm like could you
imagine if I was able to get on get a
microphone and talk with a bunch of guys
or gals about gaming and it would be out
there for people to listen to this is
crazy
like I can't believe that this is
happening so I became a real big fan of
crossfire and much more specifically
because mooch
he has he he's he has that voice that
when he comes into the room everyone
stops and and and and listens like he
has a very powerful voice and he's very
passionate now again I will tell you
this me and me and mooch we don't agree
on a lot of things and but we you know
that's life you don't always agree
that's that's understandable so I got
into Twitter in 2014 when I was still in
the job I was like oh you know you know
learn you know learning the social media
cuz I don't really do how to pick social
medias I had to learn that when I got
into this business and ID and mooch and
I said hi I'm a just I'm a big fan of
the show I listen every Friday night
it's really great
do you ever have anyone from the
community on as a guest and he says yes
it's something we do would you like to
be on and I said oh my god are you
kidding me sure and I would love to be
on you tell me when and I made my first
appearance on crossfire and I think it
was I want to say it was June
it was like yeah was it it might have
been Mayor June of 2017 mm-hmm and I
made my first appearance and I wasn't
nervous because I used to you know when
I was when I was working for the New
York City Police Department most of most
of my career was spent as a youth
officers I worked with kids and I would
go into classrooms and auditoriums and I
had to speak in front of you know large
amounts of people and I loved doing it I
think he was saying earlier like we're
Italian so we we like totally torkoal's
over the way it is did you like the Dare
stuff and stuff like that too what's
that were you were you two did you have
to go into the school and do like the
Dare type stuff yes I did I dressed up
like McGruff I you know I did all kinds
of fun stuff like that with the kids I
would volunteer after work to play
basketball to you know the coach I loved
it it was just it's such a rewarding
career so he has me on and I kind of
held my own cuz we're talking about
games it's not hard if you know you love
it it's really easy to talk about and
you know IRA see I didn't know is he
crossfire see III run my shows
differently we're crossfire you kindly
you kind of got to get yourself in there
you don't say when someone stops talking
you got to jump in when you have your
point yeah uh and I wasn't used to that
so I didn't say much and then the next
week he invited me back and he says hey
Baum would you like to be on I'm like oh
oh my god two weeks in a row
freaking holy cow yeah sure and then the
third week prior to the show going live
he has DM to me and he goes listen boom
getting a lot of people to say they like
what you have to say would you like to
be on regularly and I'm like okay now
someone's got to pinch me this is
ridiculous I'm on the show that I
actually used to listen to my mother oh
come on you get in me and I was on it
for a full two years and watching how he
did the show and seeing how many people
were so people responded to it I was
like you know my brother my brother Neil
mental who's probably gonna listen to
this
is next time I he's gonna punch me
because he has been after me for years
to do this not so much the writing thing
he says you have a personality that
people want to listen to because you are
relatable try the YouTube thing by
YouTube come on that's for kids I don't
know whatever and so what wound up
happening is I talk with my brother and
and I'm like you know you know neo
mentally I'm kind of thinking about
doing my own channel and I gave it the
all right you know I I'm self-taught
listen I'll tell you this right now I'm
not ashamed to say it I'm a barbarian
Algie like I don't like like that that's
why I like I guys that I follow like
dealer gaming for instance and Cody's
would there I really you know enjoy
working with them but more so listening
to their content because they're very
technical did you know they they know
they really the inners and I I know I'm
obviously I was a police officer I
worked with technology but not like on
this level right I never knew had to
edit a video make some nails advertise
use cameras you know who want to do my
unboxings I actually have lighting
equipment I died that was a little
self-taught and then I after being on
crossfire for a couple of months I got
the itch to want to do my own thing like
I had my own voice that I wanted to get
out there and talk about and dude it
just has been the greatest two years of
my gaming 40-year gaming career these
last two years have been nothing short
of a magical mystery tour right it's
from all the stuff that you that you're
talking about with how it went from
something that you never expected to
happen to the point where now like you
you are so busy and I think you're
probably one of the busiest people as
content creators that I know of it's
kind of it's kind of amazing to hear how
you know you're driving your wants
to be on to a show and listen to a show
kind of drove you to want to produce
your own channel wanting to do your own
thing so - I I want to hear like you
know about your channel and why
everything about it well one thing that
I needed to do from the minute I put
this channel together was to make sure
that it was built from the grant with it
from the ground floor up with the
community in mind the community had to
be front and center on everything that I
do and making them a part of the the DNA
of double-barrel gaming was an absolute
must and and you know going back to and
it's funny because I would have if you
would have asked me could you have
incorporated your police career into a
gaming career I would have told you
you're out of your mind because but I I
spent like I said as much time as I
spent as a youth officer I worked in
community affairs so I dealt with a
large portions of the community and
everybody I meet doesn't matter
I'll female gay straight it doesn't
matter what religion black white blue
purple everywhere I dealt with everyone
and it was it was an amazing part of my
career and having that experience was
that's why I think it was so easy for me
to incorporate how I work with the
community now because everyone is
important to me it doesn't matter
and your and and it doesn't matter how
much experience you have or you don't
like for instance I I I'm very I love
paying it forward so the same way mooch
allowed me to be on his show um when
someone reaches out to me in the DMS is
hey hi poom I'm a fan I've never podcast
it but I'd like to they immediately get
an invite because it's the right thing
to do why I mean why wouldn't you want
to do that it
for me so it's literally the least I can
do
and so but getting back to the channel
it's all of the oil I mean I listen as a
content creator you're gonna try things
and things are gonna fail and I and I've
started you know new shows and they just
didn't resonate with the community or
they just they just did not hit and you
know that's it that's life do you have
to you have to constantly the one thing
that's amazing about YouTube is that
there are millions of content creators
millions upon millions and you have to
work hard if you want to be noticed yeah
you know have to be consistent with your
content you have to be innovative with
your content you have to talk about
things that people want to hear but for
me how I do my content is I do it like a
kid in poise or us like you take a kid
and you put that kid in Toys R Us and
everything is incredible right like no
matter what he or she looks at it's
incredible because they're in a giant
toy store so when I go and I decide what
stories I'm going to use for each show I
don't look at it as a content creator
trying to make get a story for a show I
look at the story and be like that is
awesome I am so going to talk about the
House of the Dead remake that they're
doing or this or whatever so I look I
look at it from the eyes of a fan and I
think that resonates with a lot of
people do you do you feel like your your
work and like because it seems like you
do it like a lot of volunteer work right
yeah so does it do you feel like because
of your love for gaming and because you
always want to give back that's why you
wanted to become a content creator is
that like why you want just to start the
channel like to kind of like get that
information out there you know what it
is I always thought I had a voice for
gaming like I always wanted to be able
to talk about gaming what I didn't
realize is that people
actually wanted to listen you know when
you know one of the things that I do and
I I think it's a responsibility you you
cannot take your fan base the fact let
me just say this the fact that I
actually have people that would be
considered fans it freaks me out I want
you to like I don't it's it's hard it's
a hard pill to swallow because I'm just
a regular guy you know what I'm saying
but when you get messages from people
that say hey boom listen I I just I
found your show I worked a midnight
shift it's usually very boring and I you
put out so much content that every every
night I have something to listen to I
want to thank you for that when you hear
that when you read stuff like that like
saying it right now I have goosebumps
because I just can't believe it to be
honest with you like I really honestly
cannot believe that someone would
actually say that so getting back to the
responsibility part I make sure and I
and want it's it's like a pet peeve for
me one I say hello to everyone in the
chat not just a general hey chat you
know welcome to the show when I see you
come on I'm writing the person I say
welcome welcome my brother welcome you
know good friend or whatever I love to
welcome everyone and when they write
their comments on youtube I make sure
even even some of them I've gotten some
pretty brutal nasty ones that I don't
understand where they come from because
I think I'm a pretty fair dude but
that's life you know what I'm saying
people matter with not everyone's gonna
like you I get its the toxicity of the
Internet that's what I that's what I
call it it's just the toxicity you know
I know
people make mistakes but like how do you
engage like how far is too far
well you see I mean they're like I'm
very active on Twitter I think I'm
closing in on my god like 70 something
thousand tweets it's ridiculous it is so
absurd
that I treat so much it's it's it's in
most embarrassing but you do you do come
across people that just sometimes
they're just not nice and you know what
look let me just tell you this again I
have to hearken back to my 21 years as a
nucleus officer some of the things that
I've been called some of the things that
have been said to me have been so so
horrendous but but I I gotta be honest
with you I I really it nothing you could
possibly ever say ever bothered me I
don't know if I come off that way but
really you could you could say something
about my mama and I would thank you I
appreciate very kind of you to say
nothing anyone could say would would get
me like Toto to start cursing or acting
cool it's just it's just not in my DNA
now will I go back and forth with
someone like if I'm trying to do a point
and I if I see that the that basically
I'm ice-skating uphill I just popped a
conversation and I either block them and
I don't hate blocking people even the
a-holes all right makes me feel kind of
dirty I know that sounds ridiculous I'm
even at the same time sometimes try not
to block I do like the mute button but
you're not really hearing them so it's
not moving so terrible right Cicely I I
again I you know what listen I'm gonna
be honest with you what you know you can
say whatever you want about me to look
mama you said with a it's when you
attack my integrity I think that's
probably where I have almost I don't
want to say a rage because I don't know
I really I'm really yeah you know I like
the mellow I like to consider myself
like Ferdinand the bull is my favorite
book my favorite child book of all time
awkward man wanted to do is stay under
his shady tree and smell us Wow it's icy
that's me all right and then you know
obviously he gets stung in the ass and
then he goes buckwild everyone's afraid
of him see that's what it takes from me
like it's very rare do I ever even like
raise my voice because it's it's you
know with the you know my dad what would
help me as a police officer is you know
my father used to tell me he goes to a
couple of really important things first
of all the I say it almost at the end of
all my shows first of all it doesn't
cost anything to be not the big thing
and the other thing that he taught me
was treat people how you want to be
treated
mm-hmm those two things resonate it so
well me and they've really helped me
throughout my career but there was one
other thing that he used to tell me and
you can't really see me because I'm
because I'm average seen on camera but
he said when you come into a situation
and used to how he would walk into it is
he'd say he would take his hand and
raise it above us at his V you start
here boom
I'm not well craig you didn't call me
Craig it's fine nowhere to go if you
start here but if you low and it works
all the way up to it well then it was
brought it was brought to that level by
that person right those things really I
mean I carried those so close to the
vest literally my bulletproof vest
throughout my career and it always
served me well and I used those same
ideology that my father taught me since
I was a kid on his lap through the way
the way I handled my business on social
media because social media is a very it
could be at the greatest place and you
meet some amazing people but at the same
time you can always you know that you
can meet some really terrible people
that have a lot of terrible ways of of
dealing with life and other you know it
costs nothing to just simply keep your
mouth shut
yes like sometimes we you just should
not comment you know like there's plenty
of times where written
went out and then erased it and put my
phone down and go about my day that I've
done that more time you know I just I'm
like you know what it's just not even
worth getting it and you hit the back
button and moving $0 yes cut kognito he
by the way he hopped into the chat and
said look boom
hashtag officer friendly and that's for
real they did they they called me that
on my beat because of being I love being
a good guy I think it I live for being a
good guy but getting back to the channel
now I've had a lot of people ask me this
like we're just double-barrel gaming
boys because you're a cop is because you
know you like guns the answer is no it's
nothing to do with that whatsoever as a
matter of fact one of my all-time
favorite films is the Evil Dead 2 I have
a story for you about that but continue
to go so my brother and I we are the
biggest Evil Dead fans we loved 1 2 3
and the this is my boomstick from yes
darkness is where I you know tried to
play with the name of mr. boomstick XL
and and it was actually my gamer tag and
I'm like oh you know double-barrel
gaming let me see if that works
and I just I went with it no one had it
no one had an active double-barrel
gaming and I coined it and that's how
double-barrel gaming became what it is
did you watch did you watch the TV show
that's recycle dead I watched it also I
actually thought it was good people
thought oh I love I love the whole
series it's great there is a what's it
called Bruce Campbell's books have you
read them you know what sadly enough I
did not all right we'll talk after after
the stream I have them on audible I can
friend them to use if you want to listen
to them game they are hilarious
I am bill it's gotta be fine oh my god
some of the stuff that he
says and some of the stuff that he comes
up with I'm just like oh my god it's in
this stuff between him and sam raimi as
they were producing Evil Dead it's just
fantastic and kognito thank you very
much for that bronze the subscription
here on the iron Lords podcast channel
very nice yes yes but but but continue
double-barrel gaming that's that was
your name that was the brand you became
that you started and then where did the
multiple podcasts come from underneath
that well breakfast with boom was the
first show and it's funny because all of
the shows the names themselves came from
okay double bow a double bow gaming came
from obviously the movies where I came
from I love Roose Campbell and Evil Dead
but did the names of the shows they all
came at the most unusual times I was
online paying for groceries at stop and
shop and breakfast with boom just popped
into my head so I went to my phone and I
wrote it down yeah I typed it in and
myself and I went to my brother and I
went to another friend that I did I you
know kind of bounced things well for
like what do you think about brick was
it boom oh that's great okay so that's
so I was online at stop and shop and the
xbox factor podcast I I think that one I
was on the elliptical listening my I
might have even been listening to one of
the iron Lords shows when I was on
elliptical because I was trying to pass
the time
that you're on them for a mile and a
half oh and and that's you know
obviously it's it's it's you just want
to get anything you what you want to do
what you have to do but you want to just
get it done mm-hmm and the xbox factor
podcast came from I believe it was in
the gym and primetime gaming which is
the show that I just launched I think I
launched it in the beginning of
September was the first shows right
after Labor Day was the first show you
actually launched that two weeks after
we started oh my good yeah yeah I saw I
said oh no it's fine it doesn't matter
to me but I just I saw it
like who's got another show us like how
does he have the time but that's that is
another question I want to ask you after
you tell us about the primetime of the
room yep primetime with bullies you know
see what happened was this I I noticed
that the nighttime shows usually drew a
big crowd because obviously people are
home my people are Network and you know
I had I had worked on the crossfire
podcast for two straight years I barely
ever took a Friday off
mm-hm and my wife who is not only my
confidante my best friend the love of my
life she has been in my corner and a
supporter of this dream of mine in a way
that is just it is just really no words
to attach to how thankful I am for her
hurt you know her support on this and
you know I noticed that because before
getting into the whole podcasting thing
we used to go out Friday nights go to
the movies go to dinner you know get
dinner out come in just watch a flick
and just hang out go out shopping
because I enjoy shopping we go all the
way up to nine you went to do our
shopping here and III took Friday's
Friday nights away from her and she
didn't put that complaint one peak
because I was living the dream right she
was there you know and supporting me and
we and after I got done with correspond
we'd go on Netflix and make popcorn and
we just continued our thing and I you
know I had expressed to mooch that you
know I did you know that I I really
needed to kind of I would guests every
now and again but I had to give my
Friday's back to my wife I thought it
was only fair and then I was doing the
two shows of my own shows and then and
then I I just I noticed that there was
RDX on Tuesdays there was Xbox nation on
Wednesdays there was Sofia's show on
Thursdays and it was correspond Friday
it was like Monday doesn't have a main
show
and that's where primetime came in
actually my wife helped me with that
because I was virtually gonna start the
show at 7:00 and she's like well you
know primetime is 8 o'clock and has a
prime-time 2nd so I took what she said
and I primetime gaming and I came up
with the graphics you know making it
like that that 80s retro look and I'd
actually did that one myself all of my
art work is done by graphic God graphic
God is responsible for almost all the
artwork that the channel has but the
primetime I created myself and I figured
you know what if it doesn't work it's
just gonna be something that I tried and
it didn't work and it turns out that we
must hit something because three
Monday's ago we had 630 people watching
Wow like I could not honestly believe
that many people turned out for that
show and then the following week we had
430 and the last night was I think
everyone was watching the Chiefs game we
only had we had 170 we had a hundred 70
people watching but it's it's it seems
to have picked up and it's actually
become one of the more popular of the
three shows so now I think you want to
ask where do I find the time right yes I
am always writing that is the thing we
were talking pregame and as first of all
I have my gamer scores 260 I think it's
12 it's 65,000 I think it's somewhere
around there I love gaming I can gain
till the cows come home
I love it it's I can game on anything I
prefer to play on the Xbox but like when
the Sony first party games come out I'll
play there or and then the big Nintendo
ones i buy i buy all the first 40 for
both of those consoles but I have I have
found a kind of like a second love that
writing for me personally is just as
exciting as holding a controller and
playing like the news
our Ward's game you know I love to write
I never knew that I never realized that
I did first of all that I had the skill
of the towel to actually write a show
and as I just never thought of it but
how much fun I'm having what it is is is
crazy I'm like having so much fun so
there's a good time of the of the
evenings where my wife goes to sleep
because she's still working and I
receive retired and I could easily just
pop out you know get on whatever you
know set game a and play a lot of the
times I'm heading over this computer
because I I constantly I read about 50
articles all right but at least 50
articles a week my reading comprehension
has gone through roofs since doing it
because you know obviously you have to
keep up to date you want to do want to
put content out that the people are
excited about that are talking about and
I write the shows IOC with anyone that's
been a guest that knows that when I'm
setting the show notes they are like
yeah like when you say writing like what
do you mean what are you doing yeah I
mean it's it's hard again I could send
you a sample what I wanted how I break
it down in know a normal show for me
that I write is anywhere between 35 and
4 4,000 words for one one show mm-hmm
and the way I break it down is I'll read
the article and if there are quotes from
like say for instance Phil Spencer I you
know obviously I will write the quote
from what those but usually if it's a
quote I will copy and paste it I want
that right it's because I need the exact
quote I want to make sure that it's
legit but everything else that in that
one topic is all my opinions and that
and the information that I got from that
topic so I've read that I read the
article usually multiple times and then
I write a you know topic one and the
topic one's gonna have what the article
is about what my feelings about worried
about about what was written quotes it
quotes dates
and then at the end of it it's a panel
what do you think about you know article
what about what Phil said or whatever
and and I do that I have usually
anywhere between seven and eight of
those topics and those seven or eight
topics I over produce the shows because
what I depending on how big the panel is
that they normally my panels are like
five or six people sometimes they even
balloon to seven when you have that many
people and there's a big topic you're
not gonna get to all your topics you're
probably gonna get to three or four so
I'm gonna have four written topics that
I could push on to another show like for
instance Friday's like like if I have
topics left over Friday morning from
breakfast with boom and they're relevant
topics and they're important topics I'll
push it over to primetime gaming I will
you a good a good good portion of the
time I will rewrite it because more
infamous maybe there's more information
that has come out on the on the on the
on the particular topic so I'll rewrite
that topic and put it in there and so
I'm always writing I'm constantly
reading and writing and just and just
it's it's it's when you say it out loud
it seems like it's overwhelming but when
you're doing it for me at least it's not
right so you end up pretty much writing
how many days a week would you say every
day I want to say at least but even if
it's only for an hour I'm probably
writing six days a week yeah yeah and
then you from there the the topic length
you would say how much how long would
you say your topic lengths are on your
shows I mean you know what it really
really varies the topic it does because
you see okay this is what I was saying
early before I am I just want to clarify
because people okay when you're with
like friends you take four-cross re for
instance right crossfire is like the
Wild West
hmm right um you could if you if you
don't know how to get in there it just
imagine it's it's like a it's it's like
a bunch of horses in a pen and they're
all jockeying for position and if you're
not willing to get yourself in there
when you see the opening you you know
I'm saying you could miss your
opportunity to speak that's why it's
called crossfire that's why mood is the
show whereas my shows everyone's voice
is important and for me for me as a
producer of the content it is my job not
to make myself the the spectacle it's
not it's not it's not about me it's
about the people that are on the panel
that have taken the time out of their
day to be on this panel because they
want to talk about games so because they
want to talk about games I have to make
sure that whatever they want to say is
heard now obviously I run a PG show we
very rarely curse every now and again
an f-bomb will drop very rare but I try
to keep it PG but getting back to the
actual person there's no set time limit
like for instance so shady
who's on two of my shows he loved his
like myself he loves to talk and he's
very elaborate and he and he does like
he does good rants people really like
your rants because he doesn't rant just
to rant he rants because he's passionate
so when he gets on a subject he may be
on topic one talking for 12 minutes and
that's perfectly uh that's perfectly
fine now someone will come on the back
end of shady and they'll talk for seven
minutes and that's perfectly see there's
no set time because my my goal as a
producer is to make sure I run a
two-hour show and it's it's it's
important to me to get as many topics as
I can because you wanted you want the
fans to be entertained but at the same
time the people that are dedicating
their time to be there there's a balance
so I don't have a set time so if I only
get to three or four topics on a show
originally scheduled seven oh well you
know we got all four topics yeah that's
that's the that's what I find very
interesting how the kind of like our
show here like we really don't have a
set you know XYZ kind of format where a
lot of shows like yourself like you have
topics like we kind of like you're
saying the Wild West that's kind of like
how we operate because that's just
that's just the way I like to talk to
everybody here and L likes to talk to
everybody in and that's kind of like how
the whole stream team is because we're
all streamers we we stream almost every
night and we don't have set topics we
play our game and we just talk about
random stuff and that's the really
interesting part how you how you have
like these because you guys do more news
ish podcasts and YouTube and that's how
your content creation is so you have
your set conversations so it's kind of
interesting to see how each of your
channels kind of kind of work and all of
your all of your podcasts are just a
little different which is very very
unique okay do you do you see how like
each of them are different yes and nip
and the purpose and they're purposely
done like that they I do it like that
for the reason because again when I
produce these shows I put I put a
significant amount of pressure on myself
I truly truly do and you know it's funny
I don't feel like I'm doing it but I
know that I kind of bully myself I know
that sounds ridiculous but I feel a set
of responsibilities because we know I
I'm gonna be a magazine I'm being very
you know very being very frank here the
fact I have anyone listening to me I and
I truly mean this completely still blows
my mind
truly truly blows my mind that anyone
wants to have to say so with that said
it is my responsibility as a content
creator to
make sure that the people that are
taking the time of their day to listen
to a show that I put out
it had equality content and you know and
because I have there are a lot of
content creators that only have a one
show and they put all of that into the
one show I have three shows and yes it
is a bit of an undertaking for sure but
I have to make sure that each individual
show is slightly different that oh that
that just does things a little different
to make it different than the other two
shows because when people tune in you
just don't want to hear the same stuff
you just really don't want to hear
because then it's regurgitated right
like white in if on Monday again unless
it's a real if it's a big to do topic
like for instance the gears thing
there's be stuff that the awards that's
gonna be talked about it's gonna be
talked about on the Xbox Factor podcast
and we're probably gonna come back
around on and onto it the if not on
breakfast would boom maybe on Monday
won't be on all three shows but III my
opinion is already out there but my
panel I want to hear what they have to
say because then they'd like myself
they're probably gonna want to talk
about it so I want them to have fun
right and I and so I may bring that that
topic back around but change it in a way
where it's not so direct like you know
it's media bias and that's what we know
that's that that's the story we're
running with it I'll turn it in a way
where it will be constructive talk
it'll be criticism but it'll be
constructive criticism it's not gonna be
like what we talked about on this show
so yeah a little bit of a I guess a
tightrope walk if you will but that's
the fun of it it's the challenge of
trying to get this done and the people
enjoying it is like I said it is it
still completely blows my mind that
anyone likes to the show it's really I'm
not even being facetious I really
honestly feel that way
so because you have I'm sorry I'm
jotting notes cuz I have questions I
don't want to break your cat but break
your flow because you you originally I
assumed did this almost like a hobby I
would assume yes yeah do you do you feel
like now it's turned into like a job for
you or is it like a hobby that you
really really enjoy that it's almost
like turned into the point of like it is
it is quote unquote a job but it's still
just like a huge passion project of
yours oh you know what all of that
because yes it's a job it is it is
become a job because our job yes yes
absolutely I mean obviously you know I
have I have merchandise like I have
t-shirts right I I'm currently in the
process of designing three I'm not an
art I'm not an artist do not I I could
barely put a stick figure together yes
what I I'm I'm putting these things
together and again this is a new venture
it's something I've never done before
I'm kind of like I said I'm also taught
but for the show it's it's a job sure
it's a hobby definitely but for me it's
more of like you said it's a passion
project because I get to talk about
gaming and I get to do it in a way where
not I I get to have you know for me the
for me actually the the biggest joy of
all of the everything that I do is
interacting with the community getting
to meet all I went to e3 for the first
time I actually met l-boogie
at e3 it's my first three with that yeah
i it was my first III ever I've never
been an again bucket list right and the
iron Lords thanks to kognito and Kings
guidance yeah they got me there
they got they explained to me what I had
no idea what the hell yeah I know them
as hell I know that but they they they
explain
in a way they put it in front of me in a
way that was understandable I got there
because of that right and meeting
getting to hang out with all these
people that I worked with and and and
never met before in real life and just
talked on shows my god it was it was
amazing it was so cool and you know and
getting to meet like for instance III
and I talked about this whole time
a guy that's a that's a she's a friend
now but he's a fan of the show his name
is Frederick Jackson known aka Gotham
guy hmm and Gotham guy had originally
reached out to me and I didn't see the
message and he was gonna give me his
plus-one to get into Fan Fest Wow I
missed it I'm like oh man so you know I
would say I kept trying to try anything
get in mmm we get to e3 and I'm like
okay I got into every event and I got
into as press believe I got to press I
got into Bethesda as press like I
couldn't believe it like it's like it's
ridiculous yes and then he D and me at
e3 and says hey boom my plus one blew
out his shoulder in the gym he can't
come do you want my plus one
oh my god are you kidding me yeah of
course I want your plus one and he he
sent me all the information I reached
out to the Xbox opinion and they got
back to me and in just it's it's it's in
instances like that that those are those
are things that knew only a dream of and
B I am never gonna forget for the rest
of my life so it's it's it's a passion
project it at times it's it's to be
honest to be completely fair it's never
actually ever felt like oh geez I gotta
write again I just I just I just I've
always been that I've always had a very
high motor especially like on the job
like I was always the guy I mean I ran
into when was running the other way I'm
always running in that's just this is a
DNA is built but I've always been a
community first person and like I said
it again it's it's it's both of my DNA
I feel a sense of responsibility that
people tuned in looking for the show if
it's there I have failed I have failed
content creative so it's never actually
felt like a job but if it did it'd be
the greatest job in the whole world when
you went when you were at e3 did you
have people coming up to you like fans
oh my god it was the craziest experience
for you it is it was embarrassing for me
embarrassing for me and I'm a very
social person but because people would
hear the voice I hate my voice by the
way I absolutely love my voice I really
do I heard myself and I'm like that's an
ugly voice man I don't I don't like it
but people like the voice and I would be
talking and I actually had people be
like mr. boomstick and I'm like yeah oh
my god I'm a fan Ashok I take a picture
and I'm like yeah of course you can but
my god crazy like I don't believe this
is happening and it's it's yeah it
happened quite a bit because they for
the voice apparently is very unique yes
I hate I hate my voice but apparently
they if you hear it people like oh I
know that voice and it did happen and
and and to be completely honest it's
it's it's it's very surreal when people
want to take a picture with you I'm like
oh my god the honor is mine I'm taking
you taking a picture with you that's
that's good enough for me and yeah it
did happen and it was like I said for me
it's in my inside I was actually
actually a little embarrassed I'm like
oh my god I can't believe this is
happening oh it's I find it kind of an
amazing thing when you have like fans
being able to walk up to you and you
know I'm nowhere near you but I met like
one guy in Trader Joe's who ended up see
what seeing me wearing my Twitter and he
was like ah how's it goin what's going
on he's a cure on twitch now like I
produce some type of like rapport with
the guy that now he's in my twitch
channel I have every like every couple
of days but it's it's so weird cuz I
still go to that Trader Joe's and he's
like Pete what's up man I'm like hey
Greg how are you doing like you know
talking to him it's just
find it's so weird and awkward but at
the same time you have this really
amazing connection because of gaming and
it is a fantastic thing so um you
weren't you you said before that your
wife you know she supports you with
everything that you're doing and neo
mental your brother he ends up you know
supporting you like how how was your
other family when you kind of told them
that you were you were gonna do this and
you were gonna you know produce all
these podcasts and this is this is what
you're gonna do
how did they feel well I mean obviously
you know like I said my brother my
brother was very supportive obviously he
was pleased for years like my mom is
she's you know she's she's little older
you know I'm saying she she she she
she's like oh you're doing what you
always wanted to do she knows I was
wanting be in gaming way or another but
you know it's it's I've never been told
you shouldn't do this because you're too
old because they're folks I'm gonna be
50 years old next year you know I'm
saying they're not a lot of 50 year olds
doing the podcast business do not act
like a 50 year old by the way well you
know what as I say Doyle time I think
it's the games that keep me really young
I mean like I have a mohawk you know
what I'm saying I as a matter of fact
they had a mohawk in the department very
very very few come and yes I had my
balls broken by a lot of horses they did
I thought it yoomin ëismí with the
public I loved because it was different
people didn't just see a white guy in a
blue uniform I I really mean and it's
just you know it's at the job has
changed and I hate to say this it's it's
not as like when I got on it was
community pushing pushing pushing
community I don't necessarily know if
it's like that anymore it seems very
robotic I haven't been on in five years
so I know it's changed significantly but
I always wanted to stand out in a way
that made me approachable but that's
like that was my goal is to make
somebody not afraid to want to you know
stop and ask a question or ask for help
I mean that that was that was my job
it's what we swore into dirt but yeah
I've always been supported for this and
uh you know it's it's it's been great
and the the reception of the of the of
the fan base has been crazy good like
it's it is unbelievable how you know cuz
I'm gonna be honest like I'm a very very
transparent person I don't mind talking
about anything I'm not embarrassed but
it works it should I love about you know
getting bears but anything it's the
truth it really is up and putting myself
out there as a former New York City
police officer was a tremendous risk a
tremendous risk and I figured well I'm
in the [ __ ] now pardon my french and I'm
just gonna let out and you know what I I
think it it has worked in my favor
because I think people tend to if you
could be transparent about something
like that I I think that it can it gets
real easy to talk about gaming's and I I
kind of want to just push that message
out there where you know I know that we
all get caught up in the my box is
better than your box and then they will
in my blue flag is better new green or
my red and leg is so ridiculous day
isn't it amazing how gaming your piece
of plastic just gets all of these people
together and when it's due when it's
running right when the engine is running
smooth everyone is just enjoying
themselves it doesn't matter race creed
color sexuality and all of that in just
for the floor and it's just it is what
drives me to really be involved with
this community because again I
understand it's the plastic ward
shenanigans it's it's always gonna be
there it was there when I was a kid when
my you know Nintendo you know genesis
does what Nintendo don't you know I'm
saying I did that's been for years you
know my Odyssey is better than your
Atari 2600 you know I'm saying it's
right it's just a ridiculous it's silly
it's silly but at the end of the day
it's just it gaming just
it bridges all it's it's just such an
amazing thing and that that's that's
that that ideology is what drives me be
the cotton created that I am right now
I've seen that you've done because
you've done so many videos of multiple
different things um do you have a
favorite unboxing video that you've done
yeah I do actually
it's funny because one of my favorite
ones nearly killed me and I and I'm not
being facetious either I did a boxing of
the fallouts 76 power armor helmets the
bird the box was massive his so big took
up almost the whole table so trying to
get the correct camera angle and stand
off today it took me about I want to say
almost six and a half hours to do I
don't know eight or nine minute video it
you had to get all the angles right I
had to keep checking but the the end
part of it is where it really got tricky
because it's a it's a helmet that you
could wear so I was trying to figure out
a way to get the microphone underneath
the mask and then put the mask on and
then obviously you're trying to talk
with it those those masks are hot they
get OH ultra hot in there I have a buzz
my wife says that big guy I it's not
this one it was the one that they sold
separately I think there was like some
sort of asbestos thing over and nothing
but that deck right it was the new older
one that apparently had asbestos so
they're ridiculous
so I got the mask on and it's hard to
breathe in there it really is
so you're trying to do the your spiel
you know I'm saying okay that you know
so I had to do I think it took me about
fourteen or fifteen takes with the
helmet on to get the last 30 seconds
welcome you know thanks for tuning in
you know for double-barrel gaming is mr.
boomstick hit that like button whatever
and I was trying to do it where I was
towards the end I was getting out of
breath because the mic is right here in
the helmet it's hot as hell in there
yeah and like the 15th time I finally
got it and I wound up sitting on the III
but I took off the helmet i sat with the
in front of the fan for about 10 minutes
she was cooling off and I looked at it
I'm like okay that footage is gonna have
to go go because I'm not getting back
fricken helmet oh I would I would give
is is that the same one that you had
problems taking on and off to I mean I
only had a issue taking off because the
mic I had a wireless mic and there was a
wireless at the time I might have been a
wired mic and it was it was thin but
again is it does not a lot of room in
those things how to position it I had
and it's funny because I wear glasses
and I had to take the glasses off
because you couldn't get them on on the
underneath of the the microphone and
everyday it was it was hilarious to do
but that was probably it took me about
seven hours to tape to actually you know
set up the studio break down the studio
edit the video they do the sound do the
sound check put it up on it was it was
and I'm I don't know how many views like
I don't a--probably but you know three
or four hundred not even a lot of views
but I hadn't gotta be honest with you I
wouldn't trade it for the world I had a
blast oh yeah I actually noticed that on
Twitter you were you and I we converse a
short amount about your division statue
because I was very unused I thought you
were going to be selling it but you were
because I would want to gobble that up
because I got my statues up and on the
wall but do you have a favorite statue
that you have I do my favorite piece of
all of my collectibles and I have I have
a significant amount is probably the
titanfall one collector's edition the
the the the Titan is about two feet tall
really and it lights up it's it's I it's
it's got it's got to - no it's got two
or three its it two guys running on the
by his feet that are on the same side as
him and one guy is on the back trying to
open up the cockpit oh how it was the
box was it's probably the biggest box
I've I've ever seen in my entire life or
collects edition and it is it's probably
one of my favorite pieces my second most
favorite piece believe it or not is the
titanfall - wearable helmet I have them
side by side and it's at the helmet
happens to be my nephew's favorite
because he every time he comes over he
wants to wear it and take yeah III have
that Division one I had member I we were
talking yeah I only have that one
there's quite a few division ones is one
of there's a dark zone one that I really
want that see when Division two came out
I am I am probably one of the biggest
division fans you will you will ever
meet and Lords have gave me that net
every Wednesday at but state of the game
little notes up a little plug for
Cognito because I know he'd appreciate
that so I ended up buying the dark zone
Edition for the Xbox and then I ended up
getting the Phoenix Edition for the PC
so I have both both of them and when I
did the I have an unboxing video of them
and I didn't even want to like take them
out of the box because they they're so
amazing it's so beautiful if you can get
your hands on them I think they might
sell them individualised on the store do
it cuz it looks great that really does
I'll show you I'll show you
actually cosplayed as a division agent
really uh it was I never caught again
one of the one of those bucket list
things yeah I've always seen it I'm not
again I'm not embarrassed to do anything
I'm like you know what how about I'm
gonna make my own division and I was
comic-con 2017 I did it I did it was it
was amazing again people stopping you to
take pictures are you the division oh my
god do you know who splinter Shielders
splinter shield he's a pretty big
cosplayer for the division and I've
actually I'm sorry it's it sounds
familiar
yeah he's very popular there's actually
when you kill all of the all the hunters
you get all your all the ivory keys you
actually open up the box in Division two
inside a DC in uh what's it called in
the white house and you actually get the
splinter shield gun which is actually
something that they named after him I've
actually been trying to been talking to
him trying to see if I can get him and
to actually come on here to explain it
because he always cosplays as as hunters
and as of lately he's been doing Star
Wars falling or fallen order and he's
been dressing up like a Jedi and stuff
like that and that's just what he does
that's in and easier to rethink a player
he's a great guy so that brings me to my
next question cuz you are a Star Wars
fan am I not wrong diehard fans I start
I saw I saw episode 4 in the movie
theaters I was I was seven
oh the first time or the second time no
the third the first run the first record
I parent my parents wanted to go see if
my parents were very young and they had
me and my brother hmm and so they
enjoyed it as much as we did but I
remember seven years olds and then
they're like oh what am i watching yeah
how would you enjoying fall in order I'm
gonna tell you this I have been posting
on Twitter like a lunatic different
what I mean big things on there cuz I
don't want everyone anyone's experience
but I'm gonna tell you this without a
shadow of the doubt it is probably the
best Star Wars game in a decade yes it
is it is it is respawn storytelling at
their absolute complete and finest it is
it is an original it's Canon the
characters original Cal is an amazing he
said he's a character that carries a
tremendous amount of emotional baggage
he learn as the story goes the story is
powerful and it's not just you're you're
a typical story it is it is a really
well-written story if you're a star Wars
fan and I you know what to be honest
with you I kind of expected it only
because titanfall 2 single-player was
masterfully written so who cares about
beat me you don't say you cared about
the book yeah you know I actually by the
way III were sitting there talking about
I just literally got goosebumps Oh
like I've been playing the story and I
am a huge Star Wars fan like huge huge
beyond beyond belief
and um and yes l-boogie I did watch the
Mandalorian so you don't have to yell at
me I saw the first two episodes because
I know you're gonna yell at me see see I
knew you're gonna say um and though I
love the story and when you're going
through like I want one of those droids
like I want you know yeah bt1 I want one
like he's you know how dark solely it is
souls like the punishment for dying
Warleggan what level are you playing it
on master yeah that's what I'm playing
it on it is no it is no joke it's not
yeah like it's like
like I just got through that arena which
is not really I don't think it's giving
away anything but I just got through the
arena and my god
like my thumb hurt being able to do that
every single time yeah and I just wanted
off mirror and it's like that all the
time yeah how um boom how how about you
are you playing it on master also you
know what here's the thing I started
playing on was it there was a Jedi
Masters when I started playing that's
what I started playing on mm-hmm then I
kind of started getting my my rear
handed to me and I'm like you know I
play games if I want to punish myself
I'll bang my head against the wall all
right if I want to if I play games to
have fun and then what I decided to do
is because you see I'm I'm more of into
so I play like for instance I beat I'd
be call of duty on hard hard level I
have 1,000 out of 1050 achievements in
that I got everything I really enjoyed
this year's call duty so I I decided
that after being killed 7,000 times in
that game playing it on the hardest
level I decided that it was I was going
to enjoy the story that they were trying
to tell mm-hmm and I'm playing on the
second to lowest nothing not to gloat
but the second two lows where it's a
chal but it's a challenge where I can
appreciate the story that there's
because I you know with this game though
they like you guys were saying when you
played on that that that Jedi Master you
make one mistake and it's oh it is it's
over and that's and I agree with C I
agree with our boogie on that like it's
if there was one thing and they kind of
told us it was kind of like and it's not
dark souls but it's dark like light
and I I don't I buy them all I am
terrible at them I don't have the
patience the one game that I actually
really enjoyed that was like that was
Neil I put 90 hours and today to the
last boss and I just could not beat him
but I gotta tell you when you look you
know first of all when a game tries to
mimic another game a good portion of the
time you go to borrows from so many
games it almost shouldn't work it almost
it's it's it's almost unbelievably
shocking that it's actually working
because you could easily say that it
plays like Tomb Raider plays like
Uncharted it plays like Metroid it plays
like Dark Souls and it's and it all
works it all somehow works I don't know
how it works but it works right you guys
there yeah we're here
oh I'm sorry yeah I just I just I just
got a really weird error that came up on
across this game so yeah well I recorded
the chat yes a chat so yeah it was so
why yeah we're still good um but yeah I
I love everything about fallen order
like hands down amazing and I just I I
knew that you were a big star Wars fan I
saw the post coming up I just I had to
ask you
so do I already a one the minute they
went lie I was there I I'm not I mean
listen I know a lot of people don't like
the they know the truth you know the
sequel trilogy Zion do you know if it's
let me tell you something you you think
gaming is bare you do you think gaming
is the chatter bed like like something I
like I like a lot of like like I watched
a lot of YouTube for like comics stuff
as well you know what I'm saying
and one of one of my personal favorite
ones is the the den of nerds I'm not
sure if you guys did they're like big
into Star Wars the den of nerds is
fantastic and and you know what talk
about toxic Wow holy cow it's really
divided with the community in regards to
the the sequel trilogy but it's Star
Wars okay may not be big but it's Star
Wars I mean come on oh yeah you have to
you have to enjoy you have to kind of
bring it in but at the same time like so
I could sit here and talk about it's not
like about like how discrepancies
happens and think things back and forth
and even I can't even tell you how much
Star Wars I've ingested or my time like
my my sister-in-law's eat like memorize
the four five and six and like I'll have
all-out arguments with her about about
Star Wars stuff so but it's it's
fantastic so we've been talking I don't
even get to half of my normal questions
that I usually would love to ask people
so unfortunately we're getting close to
that time but I L did you have any more
questions for for a boom well I'm here
that a future president renovated our
cellphone I sent ya do you do you have
any questions for boom yeah cuz like
it's it's it's one of those interviews
that I was just like yeah it's almost
like in a Italian Thanksgiving dinner
when you have to like just throw in kind
of lotion well no I I'm used to it I'm
fine with it I will cut you off and I
did a couple of times I thought I'm
perfectly fine with it but one of one of
the last questions I wanted to ask you
was if you could leave
in any type of world environment if you
will like the Star Wars world or Harry
Potter or you know the the world of
titanfall or something like that or Halo
what what type of world would you live
in it would be Star Wars ten out of ten
times because yeah it's galaxy right I
mean it's it's there are thousands upon
thousands of races mm-hm and there are
thousands upon thousands of planets and
it's just it's as a person who's always
searching for you know for something
exciting to do it would be it would be a
dream come true because think about I
mean all the different me of course you
know the Empire and everything and
nobody wants to live on the rule of
Darth Vader or the Emperor but the
different thing the different sights
sounds tastes all those different things
that you can experience it would be for
me if he's darling they do they look
real nasty I'm a perfect example if you
see what they're eating on on the ship
even when you go to Star Wars where
they're blue milk I'm gonna drink in it
yeah you know I've just thought into the
blue milk I gotta be I'd be right there
with you it's fantastic
well that is that's a that's great
that's that's probably one of one of my
top choices also to be repeat to be
living in the universe of Star Wars and
you know what I'm sorry but even if I
had a little bit of force I would love
to be able to like grab my remote
control off my couch and not have to get
up I dropped my pen I'm a pen sweet like
that so that's what that's what I want
exactly exactly
be like you know ask you ridiculous
questions to people anyway so tell us
where we can find you tell us you know
all the pot
ass get tell us everything that you can
you could tell us where we can find you
boom
oh yeah the easy way to find me is on
twitter my DM is open I answer on a
regular basis to everyone if you can't
get through and there's a message
waiting I will respond I always do so
it's at mr. boomstick XL on Twitter and
if you're interested and you are looking
for content that's fair I mean you know
my content is very fair it's very
transparent and it's a lot of fun at the
end of the day it's really all about
having fun if you're looking for that
kind of content and you want to try
something new and and the negativity of
some of the content creators that are
out there that are very vocal and you're
bored of the negativity yeah give
double-barrel gaming a shot it's double
bow gaming on YouTube and I and I have
three live shows I put six plus hours of
content per week that are up there
except during holidays like obviously
next month next Thursday there's no show
but I'm doing one on Wednesday and
there's no Friday show because the
missus is often want to make sure that
she gets some rest after cooking all day
on Thursday so that we work for the pool
next week this week there'll be a show
we actually have somebody that asked a
question in chat for you boom would you
want to be a Jedi or would you the rules
and all or the Sith Lord if you're not
yet I it would it would it would be
order it would be responsibility I'd be
a Jedi for me too
oh yeah I I think I would have to almost
be one of the neutral Jedi's one of the
hardest of all Jettas they're very
difficult because obviously you yeah
yeah you kind of walk a fit you you walk
a bit of a fine line the neutrals or
death tough because you can easily go
dark you can you know and so you got to
walk that line but I would I would be I
would definitely be a Jedi I did the
darkness is just not my thing
um addict it's called a SIF and not a
Seth just come on man exactly tell us
all about you all right so you guys ate
everywhere here I actually have a
YouTube channel which I don't post
mixer I usually go on between 6:30 and
7:30 in the evenings depending on how
quickly I can get stuff tied up in the
house and yeah on Saturday mornings you
can catch me on Roma gaming podcast on
YouTube I always forget to say that but
yeah we're ladies and we give our
opinions but a men aren't invited as
well I don't know why I feel like I have
to say that but people actually ask so I
can't believe people actually would ask
that that's podcasts or podcasts they're
for everyone
Jesus yeah I'm gonna say this I want to
give you guys a lot of credit because
you mentioned I didn't get a chance to
elaborate on it I don't know how you
guys stream I don't have that pal I just
don't I am slowly getting better but I
know that there's still a lot for me to
learn it's it's streaming is one of
those things which I tell everyone it's
50% 50% lotto finding yes like 25
percent the people you know you like you
know and 25 percent you actually playing
a game because it feels like I I stream
every day from 7:00 to usually 10
sometimes later from Monday to Friday
and my numbers go up they go down they
go up they go down and you know and
everything and it's it's literally one
of the one of the hardest things to kind
of get yourself mentally through but it
is almost to the point where the people
that you know in networking is almost
more important than everything else to
get you going
it's actually a couple of conversations
I've had with with large streamers that
we're actually going to hopefully come
have them here for this conversation
starting in the new year but um that
there it's crazy because I've already
starting to book us for next year and
it's it's really intense and it's crazy
but it's streaming is not for everyone
but it's if
you are willing to put the grind in and
the time in its it is worth it boom it
really is yeah yeah for me I'd rather
write the content and put it out there
I've tried streaming it's just not my
bag yeah um well once you tell again
what your mixer is people are asking in
chat
oh it's Oh buddy Oh 208 I'll go ahead
and type it in there for you so yes it's
definitely go check her out
so uh I just want to give a couple
little little information bits out our
other two members MJ is a boss you know
he's doing his college thing you know
popping his collar and you know kicking
some button with those books and he's
he's almost done for the semester so
hopefully we get him at least four for
January but like he's like I call him
and I talk to him probably like once a
week or so and he's just he's crazy
doing this fraternity thing and doing
doing the school thing so he wanted me
to make sure he conveyed it to you guys
if you want to talk to him on Twitter it
is MJ as a boss he is silent this week
as per paternity rules they have lost
all social media privileges so hopefully
he will be back next week and our other
member old-school-style
he is like I said before working late it
is
old-school style on Twitter and he has a
paw well this is his podcast but he he
writes for Lords of gaming net doing a
bunch of tech articles and he also has
his YouTube page which is old-school
Tech Talk
where he does a lot of tech information
so yes he is there I am Snell doe SNA ly
do um you can check me out on Twitch
like I said before Monday to Friday or
when I am here doing my thing here I am
on twitter i'm on discord on the ILP
discord if you want to go check that out
it's great I want to thank the iron
Lords podcast once again for allowing us
to be here on their platform to you know
to give out you know our love and
support to their channel and to everyone
else that is here coming to say hello to
us I appreciate everyone that is coming
today it has been a fantastic seeing
people come in thank you very much
the podcast will be on almost every
single
Podcast platform tomorrow morning so
when you wake up if you want to tell
your friends you know check us out on
you know on you be it well YouTube
obviously were here iTunes Spotify all
that fun stuff
whatever the Tesla thing is we're even
on that if you have any questions for
any of our guests you can email us at
roundtable stream team at gmail.com if
you have questions and you want us to
ask you you know our guests will make
sure we get those in follow us on table
stream it is a ridiculous twitter handle
but it our name is just too long for it
to be anything else so we just shortened
it to table stream so go on there it's
mostly just information about you know
who our guests are one of the things
coming out you know things like that
which we greatly appreciate make sure
you guys check out the iron alerts
podcast they are on at 11 o'clock on
Sundays and you know all of our news
articles like boom saying he writes for
Lords of gaming net just like myself and
old-school style
MJ's a boss all of us help I hope you
wanted to write something eventually on
there for us or I put some information
but yes we're all on there I want to
thank everyone else greatly appreciate
it and we hopefully can get boomstick
back you were an amazing guest and like
I said we didn't even get to have for
the questions I wanted to ask you about
podcasting and stuff like that so
hopefully we get you back you know as
you know maybe sometime next year and we
can kind of talk some more absolutely be
my pleasure to come back it sounds
fantastic
if if that's everything remember
everyone to a dream big and keep gaming
and we'll see everyone next week we're
back on Monday next week we got indie
Falco he's a new streamer that I've
actually got in contact with through one
of our other one of our other guests
he's a great guy and I can't wait to you
know see you guys next Monday and 9
o'clock so thanks again everybody have a
fantastic evening bye everybody take
care thanks boo